we do a thing at the end called
unhelpful advice so we have is someone
email us some people ask like questions
they have problems and we try to answer
or not answer or not answer oh we can I
do give him bad advice as well okay I'm
hopeful device with body
kalila and sasha grey all right so we're
gonna keep the theme this whole episodes
been about a year ago I was diagnosed
with in inflammatory bowel disease I'm
now in remission but I still have
problems with diarrhea and bloody stool
the bathrooms at my work are very close
to the workspace you can hear everything
going on in there so after going to the
toilet for the first time at work a
month ago I decided I never wanted to go
again this sounds coming out of my
butthole were so loud and weird that
when I was done and got out all my
colleagues were staring at me and they
looked gross they looked at me like I
was gross at lunch a guy that I had a
huge crush on was laughing with other
people at the work at my work and how
loud my farts were now I haven't gone to
the bathroom for a month and my stomach
is in pain for the whole day every day
cuz I want to be I don't want to be
known as the gross diarrhea girl my
doctors haven't found anything that
makes it better and no diet has helped
should I let my loud diary out and face
the embarrassment in rejection or keep
it in and suffer I think she means keep
it in till she gets home yeah so she's
not doing um she's not doing [ __ ] breaks
at work nope she hold it in and she's in
pain oh yeah you know for me
i-i-i-i've survival techniques when it
comes to toilets tell book total to
muffle the salad no I do things like you
know sometimes there's a handicapped
toilet you know I mean my ass one you
ever seen one of those the best one it's
the best one but when there's a
handicapped guy waiting to use it you're
never happen it happened to be one not
yeah yeah I could see his crutches like
underneath the thing right so I was like
oh my god why am I in this one so when I
flush the toilet and I left did you limp
out right so I survived in public
restroom and I even say
like which was he's like and he's
probably like I'm not [ __ ] I just
have [ __ ] legs but my point is is that
um but also in if I have a loud
situation I work with the environment I
would put on your cell phone maybe some
sort of ambience music I'm beyond you
know industrial and so whenever you have
the Rihanna callback you know you
probably would do that or arm you know
what you it also could be something that
you could be very clear about with your
co-workers and tell people go listen I
have this this is a real advice I have
this um stomach issue you know I mean
it's a medical problem and I have you
know loose stool and it makes noises I
just feel embarrassed you know and so
could you not tell the boys about it not
at least not my crush no no no I would
say and so when I'm in the bathroom
cannot it can people can I have a
special sign that goes up not to go in
of Rihanna alert [ __ ] alert they're not
away another floor what is this office
situation like I don't know it's all
very close apparently yeah I would like
this is just who cares
yes who cares this is what this is the
situation at hand my farts are louder
than yours everyone does it yeah and
what I do when I'm particularly shy that
day is I just keep flushing and pushing
when I flush it smart you're not
conserving water okay for the
environment I do Mike so it's my maximum
is three flushes yeah before I get
conscious about the environment Bobby I
tried to just maximum push each one
which is not really a good thing if you
have IBS cuz you shouldn't be pushing
that hard you should just let it out as
it comes yeah could you vocally muffle
distinguish it no just go
or something you know me I do yeah but
the one thing I will tell her the advice
my advice is definitely do not hold it
in like that because it's making you
thicker and uncomfortable in miserable I
would [ __ ] it I would not also like CBD
what does it do I don't know about that
you think CBD works I on site on
inflammation
[Music]